you're also directing episodes and I'm
curious how do you direct yourself is
that a difficult thing for you yes
yeah I'm really bad at directing myself
I well the one thing I do is I one thing
I do that a lot of the actors tell me is
that because I'm writing it and and also
acting it is that I and I don't realize
it but I'm Alvin along with them when
they're talking so Henry Winkler will be
doing a scene and he says I'm going like
[Laughter]
bill would you please stop that and and
you're like I yeah I applaud you but
please and then the other thing is that
I will just be in the Edit once I was in
the Edit Bay because I don't give myself
I kind of will shoot them and when we
shoot my mic coverage when the cameras
on me I kind of just do like a couple of
takes and like alright yeah we got it
let's move on and just cuz I get I get
nervous or something and they'll be in
the Edit Bay and I'll be like do I have
any other facial expressions I have one
facial expression do we have any other
options on this and my editor ones just
like hit play and it the take ended and
then you see me on camera go alright cut
and they go you want another take and I
go no no I think we got it
loser
[Laughter]